S
REPORTING PLIS DEVELOPING
HIOWN SHOT BOX ARE
WAS A RELIEDATE FCT.
EMPLOYEES, BUT GENERATIVE A.I.
RERT BECOME A MAJOR
PUSH FOR T G
WHILE THERTEMENT
AMONG THE NECERNHE
PONTGENERA CWHETHER PEOPLE CAN D
COULD BE
CAUSED BY AN ARTIFICIAL E.DOWNLN
DEEPNTO
T TOK
.
FOR A MOMENT, THERE WAS CONCERN
AMERICA WAS UNDETA
IT WAS ABLE TO PICK UP THEIMAG .
TECHNOLOGY TO DETECT DEEPFAKES.
T WHAT
ACTUALLY CAME THROUGH, A LOT O
E OROT WHAT A REALLDS. COMPANYTH
GOVERNMENT PREPARES FOR WHAT
E OF
S.>>ENESTINUTO GROW.
>> BS CLAIM THHEWA
IOCENL B>> THEY'EENCERNED FORME.
>> DPA WAS SET8
AT THETESTATESNG BEHIND IN
ACE RACEAN IS
TTG ARCHECHNOLOGY.
ATHITING
ANS IS
.
>> DARPA HASG FOR
MOVE YEARS ON
AMERICANEARCH AND OTHEO
FIX.>> YOU CANL IN THE BUILDINGT
REALT  GENERATE
THIS FENCING.
NATION STATES HAVE ALWS HAILITYS
NEEDEDIUM
SETHAT CONTINUES TO COME
DOWN.
SES AVAILABLNE.
AND IT WILL CREATE WHATEVER.
WHAT IF WE CREATED FAKE
S ANDERSO
GO.
I KIND OF LIKE THE BEFORE.
OUT. LET HIS
EN DEEPFAKE
THROUGN >> HERE SORFAKE OF ANDR
SINGING KARA
INTEREINT AS BEI SYNTHMANIPULADE
OF THE SYNTHETIC VERSION
AND EEKS
T ON THIVER HEG
SYNTHETICALLY MA>>HILE SOMT HIR-
OUM >>
P KE BIDEN
THERE IS CCETHAT THE
TE BE USED TO
CAUSE CHANIN
THE 2024 ELECTION CAMPAIGN.
TO START THINKING CAREFULLY
ABOUT HOW THEY ARE GOING TO
COAT THESE DISINFORMATIO
THEY'RE AB THE R HAVE NEVER
DONE KIDT --
HAS ANYONE
>>AN FUN
IT IS FASCINWE AREEEBEING USED .
SOEOE YI THIS IS
WE ALSO OWSAAND
E A LOOFWI
AD WAY FOR
TIONS.T TO SCREATED A FEW MOEE F
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
THATS THE, LDAPPER.E N
A.I. ARTIST.
ILY
THAT IS YOU RUNNING AWAY FRO